hi everyone my name is Matteo Villani I
work in the Google Play games business
almond team here in London so now we're
going to talk about one of the most
important topics when it comes to
running your game as a service which is
what users should should you run the
service for and what I mean by that is
that if you monetize your game with
in-app purchases and the game is free to
install you always face your this
challenge that on one side you want as
many users as possible to come in
download your game and try it but the
other on the other side the more users
you have and the more the more sorry I
need it the more the more users you have
the more diverse there will be you will
find casual users our core users
together some will come for the PvP some
will come for PvE and some will have a
bigger budget to spend and some will be
a bit more concerned about spending so
the more the wider the funnel the more
difficult it is to please everyone and
that's where we're going to talk about
in the next 30 minutes so first of all
Adam my colleague who's a game design
experts will talk about the basics of
running your game as a service and also
some key design principles to make sure
that every player regardless of their
profile and what they're looking for
finds value in your game and is engaged
then Fred from space ape will talk about
how they approach monetization for this
different course of users how do they
target them and make sure that they
extract the LTV that they bring to the
game
they've been improving this over time
and so Fred will give you an overview of
how all the different steps that they
take and all the learnings that they
acquired in that process and also give
you a sneak peek into viewing into what
it's coming next for them but space ape
wasn't built in a day it takes time and
effort and so that's why I'm going to
come back on stage and talk about some
tools that can get you started right
away applying this concept in a very
simple way and also free which is all
is good so lots of content and so Adam
please take it away
hi everyone Thank You Mateo for that a
lovely intro Thank You Shannon for
hosting today and thank you all for
coming out to playtime London I know
it's a gorgeous day in London so thank
you all for spending with us very
excited to be here today this is my
second play time second time in London
for this and LTV is one of my favorite
subjects so super stoked to talk to you
about it today as Matteo was mentioning
let's go just do a little bit of the
basics when it comes to LTV just so we
can kind of level set before Fred from
space if it's going to come up here and
give you the master class on it so let's
do LTV 101 for a bit know your metrics
all right what is LTV and why does it
matter
LTV simply stands for lifetime value if
you didn't know that now you do it's one
of the key metrics that everyone looks
at when it comes to game development
it's something that you buy against when
you're doing your user acquisition
campaigns and it's obviously what you
look to when you're trying to monetize
your games this is the absolute value of
the average customer in your game now
it's a bit different in games as a
service which you often see in mobile
versus what you would ordinarily see in
a packaged business that you would see
saying game stock or somewhere else in a
packaged games business you've got a
binary outcome
you either have zero dollars or you have
sixty dollars from your customer one or
the other nothing in between
what games is a service it's a bit
different there's no barrier to entry
people come in you know it's it's it's
kind of free to download and then you
have this experience where you're
providing a service as the player kind
of goes through your game so LTV is not
a function of a single price point LTV
is a function of engagement times the
value that you offer your customers and
the value that they give you back in
terms of dollars so LTV in this case for
games is a service is engagement x value
so Fred's going to come up in a minute
talk about value it's got some amazing
slides on it I'm gonna talking about
engagement really quickly just to talk
about how to developers kind of drive
engagement think about it measure it so
let's think about measuring it first
it's a few ways to measure engagement
there's kind of the traditional ways of
like session length and sessions per day
and that's stickiness factor that you
often hear about daily active users over
monthly active users hint that should be
at least 15% but hard retention our
intention is one that we look at all the
time D 1 D 7 D 30 absolutely critical
and it's critical for a very very
obvious reason but I'm going to tell you
it just to make sure it sticks and you
never forget it you can't make money
from your users you can't offer them
value and they can't give you value back
in terms of their dollars if they're not
playing the game so if your D 7 and D
30s are low if players are not sticking
around in your game simply again very
obviously you're not gonna be able to
make money from them this is why it's
absolutely one of the most critical
things out there it's the number one
predictor of success in LTVs retention
now what about benchmarks people ask
this all the time so you know as a
platform we talked to every game
developer out there that we can we we
look at casual games we look at midcourt
games we look at core games and ya take
pictures of the slide all you want this
is a good one
retention is paramount but the
benchmarks are absolutely 100% paramount
you could be in this kind of darker area
blue at the bottom or but what you
really want to do is be in the sky blue
on top because that's kind of the the
the cream of the crop up there the best
games out there those are the retention
rates so if you're in the cores onra
like you know super super core MMO
something like hearthstone or something
like that I'm not saying this is their
retention rate but something in that
core area you want to be at least 10%
pushing above that even better all the
way up to casual I saw one developer
who's been working on a casual game now
and they will not ship the casual game
until they're d30 retention rate is 23%
best-in-class because they know that
that retention rate is the key predictor
of the lifetime value of their customers
and of their game absolutely important
oh and by the way we've got tools to
help you measure this who here uses Play
game services in their game yeah do you
use the player stats API some of you do
more of you should remember this player
stats API will actually help you measure
retention one thing though encourage
sign-in for your game have it in a
really good place because the more
people sign in the more data you're
going to get
want to be pushing 50 60 % it in your
game that way you can actually measure
as many people as you can coming through
your game okay so we've talked about how
to measure engagement retention awesome
stuff how do we actually engage them
retain players let's do this really
quickly before we have Fred come up and
talk about value
who here has played clash royale I want
all the hands to go up yeah awesome an
amazing game it's topical because you
know it just launched this year and
everybody loves this game let's talk
about the way that they engage players
now a game shouldn't engage players the
same way for every single player a game
should have very different ways to
engage players to gauge you more casual
players the players to play maybe once
or twice a day the ridiculously core
player is the guy that's glued to his
phone or has a battery pack walking
around you know playing pokemon go
because he can't put it down and
everything else in between you want your
game to engage players in every
different way and every different
cadence every different kind of play
style so let's look at how clash does it
here on the left you see the card shop
this card shop refreshes once every 24
hours I know that because I get a little
notification and I go to the card shop
every 24 hours to see what they've been
serving me and it's personalized to me
it's different to everybody and I want
to see what's there because I might be
you know looking for that that rare
lumberjack card and it comes up and I
want to buy it so on the minimum on a
daily basis I'm like well I got to check
what cards are new absolutely so I'm
encouraged to log in every day look at
the right this is the battle screen you
got this on-demand mode I can battle
randomly a player right now as many
times as I want so it's on-demand it is
for the most core players for the most
casual players on demand is it is not on
a clock but there's other things here on
the screen that are actually on clocks
there's there's a couple of things
there's a chess going on over here
that's going to open in two hours and 21
minutes there's a free chest that's
going to be available in 3 hours in 21
minutes so you can kind of see what
they're doing here you've got this daily
engagement mechanic you've got this
on-demand mechanic you've got these
chest opening at different times over
here you've got tournaments that start
and end in various different Cadence's
and on the far right here you've got
this every two weeks the Seas
is up and you earn rewards for yourself
and for your clan you can see kind of
what clash is doing here what supercell
is doing they're trying to engage
players in every way possible that they
want to engage with the game to the most
casual to everything in between all the
way up to the most core thank you very
much I'm going to bring Fred easy up
here to talk about value master class in
LTV everybody welcome Fred easy from
space aim
Thank You Adam hi my name is Fred easy I
head up the analytics team at spaced out
games I should put my slide on ok
so we're a mid-course studio based just
around the corner from here in Soho
we've got 3 live games they will in the
building battle genre so if you've
played clash of clans any of those kind
of games you build a base you attack
other people they attack you those are
the types of games that we make and over
the years we've had a challenge trying
to monetize players in those games and
today I'm going to talk about the past
how we used to do it I'm going to talk
about the present how we're doing things
now and we're going to take a look at
the the future as material needed to and
what we're going to be doing pretty soon
in terms of how we're gonna monetize
people so let's cast our minds back to
2013 and we're launching our first game
it's samurai siege
it was a fast follow-on clash of clans
with some additional improvements added
on and this screen here is showing the
shop in the game so this is how users
buy currency in the game they go to the
shop and there's a range of different
prices they can buy and if you spend
more in the shop if you're buying one of
these high-value ones you get more
in-game currency back you're getting a
better bang for your buck in effect so
we're trying to encourage people to
spend a bit more so with the shop what
are the what are the pros and cons of
this so there's a range of prices so
players will generally be able to buy a
price that they they're willing to spend
at just get also there's the bulk
discount that I mentioned which is going
to courage players to
maybe move up knotch in terms of how
much they wanted dispensers get it up so
one downside is we found with this
system players will turn to stick around
the same sort of transaction size so
they come in they spend $20 they tend to
stay around that kind of level generally
the other really bad thing about the
Sharpe is it's kind of tucked away if
you go into the game and you want to
spend it's two or three clicks deep
you've got to click on one thing to
bring up a menu then there's another
click to get to the shot then you've got
to click to get to the buy screen it's a
lot of clicks it's quite high friction
so you're going to lose some some spins
there basically so this system is
actually very popular like it's still
used today by a lot of really big games
clash Royale
as we just seen Pokemon go these are
number one grossing games and this is
pretty much how those guys do it like
this way works really well so there's no
shame in having a setup like this but we
want to try to improve this
so one thing we added to samurai siege
was time limited bundles so we're going
forward in time here it's the Iron Age
and with these bundles what happen is
the player would log into the game and
this would pop up it's a special offer
now you've only got so long to purchase
this there'll be a cap down so maybe
there's five hours 24 hours something
like that so you know there's pressure
there you've got a bite now or it's
going to go away and it's gone and it's
really good value so if we look at this
bundle here in samurai siege you're
getting some diamonds which is the
in-game currency you can only get that
for spending dollars well high amounts
of it anyway
we've got onyx which is another currency
which is very valuable to the players
let's than buy camps which keep and
troops and we've also got the Sun
Dragon's Tower which is a natural camp
that they can deploy in the game quite
powerful thing each of these separate
things is worth about 10 pounds
something like that ten pounds of
diamonds ten pounds the onyx 10 pounds
of Sun dragon tower
so overall they're getting about 30
pounds of value for 19 pounds so it's a
pretty great deal this is a term that we
call Eevee or estimated value and that's
a percentage in this case about 150 to
200 percent of how much better it is
than what you get from spending in the
store so with this kind of deal you've
got a lot of
good things which are going to make the
play want to buy it you know you've got
the timer ticking down you've got the
great value you've got some nice art
there all these things going to help so
we found when we launched this that we
had a big uptick in conversion and spent
so it was a great way to try and convert
people one a couple of dangers with
these things one is the players can
become training to wait for these so
what was the point of buying in the shop
if you know that one of these is going
to spawn tomorrow you might as well wait
get your value so you'll tend to see
that shop spend is cannibalized a bit
the other thing you'll see as well as
content burn you're giving away more for
the same price so you're going to burn
for your content more quickly than if
players are just buying from the shop so
there's that to think about as well and
one other thing and this is probably the
most important thing I'd say about these
they worked really well when you combine
them with a live event buy a live event
what I mean is a special event in the
game so for these build about the games
you know we might have a special event
running on the weekend where you'll be
competing against other alliances as
part of your own plan trying to beat
each other and if you theme this offer
with the event you'll see a real big
surge in your sales people love that
basically they want to spend anyway it's
an event you show them a great bundle a
lot of people going to spend at that
point so just to illustrate that this is
the graph of revenue over time for rival
kingdoms the second game we launched and
what you'll see is these two peaks in
revenue that I've highlighted here and
here
those were events which were teamed up
with a great bundle great event great
bundle and you can see that there's a
real surge in revenue during there one
thing I'll say is you don't want to do
that every week because otherwise you're
just going to fatigue players and you
won't have a strong effect but it's
something we try and do something like
once a month in our games as well have
on these great bundles when these great
events and we'll always see like a big
surge in sales as a result so that's
timeless it bundles that's how we we
used to do things we still run a lot of
these things my games I saw this haven't
gone away but we've added stuff over
time so let's take up to the present day
steam age timeline bundles so we've got
a screenshot here this is transformer
South Wars which is the most recent game
that we've launched this is an example
one of the bundles which is popping or
some nice transformer art and there what
what is a timeline bundle
no one said but I'm going to answer that
question here are some timelines so each
row on this table represents a time line
now it's a little bit blurred but on the
left here there's different spend
segments in effect so we've got nan
spender lo spender
mid spender high spender all the way up
to high spender tuned to the really big
one what this represents is what a
pleasure m'm spend has been into the
game up to that point so if you come in
and you're playing for the first time
you're going to be a non spender if you
go into short for example you spend $20
now we're going to class you as a mid
spender and what happened is with this
system we've got a series of bundles
that we've worked out that we think
that'll be appealing to users in those
segments and what will happen is there's
each time they log in each day they're
gonna get shown one of these bundles
they might buy it they might not they
might buy it and move up to a higher
timeline the next day they're going to
log in they're going to see another one
of these bundles a different one and
sometimes at these higher levels would
even go faster than one a day you might
see a couple in a day and this is much
more effective than the other version
I'm showing you for a number of reasons
so what does this work better it's
better upselling than a single price
point bundle with a single price book
bundle you've got this tension where
you've got to decide what price to put
up yeah so there's time limited bundles
if you're the guy running the game you
like I'm going to run a $10 bundle this
weekend with a $10 bundle and a lot of
people to buy X it's quite low price a
lot of people can afford it but there's
some guys you wanted to spend 50 yeah
the guys love the game they will play
all weekend they want a $50 bundle and
they're gonna buy your $10 once you left
money on the table there and the flip
side is if you won the $40 bundle the
$50 bundle there's a lot of guys who
don't spend that much their mobile game
most people in fact and they're not
going to buy it so again you're leaving
money on the table with this system
you're showing the correct bundle to the
correct user then on spending the low
value ones the high spending the high
value so it's it's tailored to to what
the customer wants the other thing as
well there's no curation required are
additional setup
so obviously it's call it off work and
setting up these timelines once it's
done it's done with the other type of
showing you there's time limit
one's every week you'll have new art
created you've got to decide what bundle
you're going to run all that kind of
stuff
with this it's it's essentially
automatics automated one just want to
set up so no no real intervention needed
what we found with this system is the
games make two to three more in terms of
lifetime value when you add this we
actually ran a split test in
transformers during the soft launch
where we had this system versus players
not having the system and yet it was 2
to 3 X increase in lifetime value this
is tried and tested for us really works
the other thing as well is this isn't
instead of the other stuff I showed you
the shop in the time limited bundle you
can have all three in your game and in
fact we have all three in our game and
they serve different purposes the shops
there for the really intense players it
would spend the whole time then I'm
going to wait for a special offer
they want their their stuff now then go
to the shop they're going to spend we've
got these timeline bundles where players
will log in um something kind of daily
thing with a login see the bundle think
oh that's a good one yeah I'm going to
buy that one and then we've also got the
tiny minted bundles which will set up
with those events as I was saying we're
the tie-in with the event we'll get
those big spikes in the weekends my kind
of thing the dangers with these ones is
pretty much the same as the time limited
bundles you've got that problem about
content burn you've got the problem
about cannibalization from the shop but
net net overall you're still going to
make a lot more money using the system
despite those drawbacks okay
so this is one thing I just mentioned in
passing quickly this is a correlation
matrix but people know what that is
we're basically at the moment we target
these things based on the user's max
spend so if you've spent twenty dollars
ever you're you're going to that middle
spender bracket even if you normally
spend five you go five five five five
five then twenty at that point you go
into the middle spender bracket and
that's that's where you're going to stay
we did a quick thing where we looked at
the correlation between what your next
spend amount is going to be so this 4
left column and all of these other spend
metrics if we know about the user so
we've got the mean of all your previous
spends we've got median the mode people
know what that is the max the lifetime
sum of all of them and actually the one
which correlated the best although it
wasn't like a winner by miles was the
mean spend so that's one of the things
which is going to
a short turn to improve these I'm going
to switch away from max spend we're
going to move on to mean spins because
we think that all be better at guessing
how much people want to spend okay so
we've talked about the present in our
games now we're going to have a little
look to the future so the rocket age
targeted bundles so imagine that we've
got all these different bundles that you
can buy in the game so there's something
for five dollars so I'm for $1 $10
there's different types you know I've
got a battle bundle which I'll help you
battle in the game I'm at the Builder
bundle which is good for building stuff
in the game
all that kind of stuff so what we'd like
to do and we've actually started work on
this already is we're going to develop a
machine learning approach where we'll
look at your users purchase history
we'll run it through a machine learning
algorithm work out what price fits them
really well and that's going to narrow
down what bundles are going to show them
so if you think you want to spend twenty
dollars you can chuck away the 20s the
ones the fives there's now going to be a
subset of these $20 bundles which we
know that you want to buy then we look
at the different types so something like
a resource bundle where you're buying
currency in the game if the player is
running low on currency they're probably
going to be more likely to buy that with
a battle bundle if you're running an
event which where you need to battle a
load they're probably going to be more
likely to want that at that point in
time so with only an effective act in as
well in deciding which bundle to show
you and we're going to choose the ones
you think you've got the highest chance
to buy relative to its price so if
you've got a 10% chance of $100 bundle
that's better than if you've got a 20%
chance to buy the $20 bundle if that
makes sense so we're going to try and
serve you one more thing we're going to
make the mess revenue so that's the plan
with this and we've actually as I
mentioned we started building this we
tried a few different approaches the
moment of trying and nearest neighbors
model which is working pretty well for
guessing the price and we think that
this is really going to take things to
the next level in terms of how well this
system works
one last thing allowed on this is that
you should include a random element when
you're deciding which bundle to show I
know that sounds a bit weird cuz you're
like why put all this effort into you
know deciding what price we're going to
show in like which types going to sell
better sometimes you can you're throwing
around development the reason is I found
using these type systems in the past is
if you just save it completely
algorithm sometimes it would just keep
showing the guy the same bundle which is
kind of weird and not a good customer
experience so it's good to have a random
element some kind of round development
just so there's some variety and some
freshness that still comes into what
you're rotating and showing to the user
okay so that's the the rocket age and
now I'm going to hand over to Mateo he's
going to talk about some of the Google
tools but you can help you do this kind
of stuff but that's hard to follow I
mean that's really interesting stuff and
as you can see it's not easy stuff so
that's why I'm here I'm just you know
relax you you don't have to be in the
rocket age you can start with some
simple tools and hopefully the tools
that we built we'll get you started not
at the Stone Age but maybe the steam age
so you already have a way to target
users and optimize your LTV without
having all this technology and resources
already invested in it so let's start
with the first tool that I think is very
relevant here when it comes to
optimizing your game design and engaging
different types of users this is the
time series page in your developer
console you get this as part of Google
Play game services and what it does it
shows you it's a very clear picture
maybe clear is not the right word
because at the beginning it looks a bit
confusing but it gives you a very clear
picture of what your how players
interact with your game every symbol
here has a meaning every symbol is a
different action that a user is taking
in your game so a symbol represent
purchase event another symbol represent
completing a level or an achievement and
you see the sequence of actions that
every users have taken this is a sample
of your users it's up to 100 and you can
see how they interact the first thing
you can do with this report is see what
action lead to what you what matters to
you for example what have they done
before they made their first purchase or
what are they done before churning and
so you can optimize your game overall
and see where if you have any issues but
where it becomes even more powerful and
relevant to this talk is that you can
actually filter this
report by different types of users so
for example users that have made a
purchase and users that haven't made a
purchase or that expend some amount and
then users I'll spend more and you can
start understanding the differences what
really are the different behaviors what
they're looking for in your game
depending on what type of category of
users they are so it's a very good way
to get some insights and and design your
game based on what type of users you
have and not just one size fits all in
the same similar reports a similar
insights you can get from the funnel
report which is also available in the
developer console for free if you
integrate Google Play game services and
again we take this data based on then
signing in through their Google account
so you should make it easy for them to
do that and what it does it shows you
our users go through different steps of
a funnel that you create so you can set
any event you want it could be steps in
a tutorial it could be levels in your
game it could be series of random events
that matter to you as a sequence in your
game and you can see how they progress
through each of this step and where they
leave so that's that's actually again
very powerful overall for your game to
find friction points and road blocks
that you can improve and get rid of but
again this is much more useful when you
start filtering it by different types of
users because you can understand what if
what users have problems in your game
and what types of problems they have
depending on what they which group they
belong to as you see here it's alighted
the different types of audiences that
you can filter for in this case or if
they spent less than three dollars spent
more than ten dollars they haven't spent
at all and you can see what are the key
differences between them so this is a
very alread already on itself the quite
impactful way to to rethink your game
this is an example from max games who
recently use this report to improve the
game stick words stick wars legacy and
they reduce churn in level six by forty
percent just by using these insights but
again they employ
thing here is that these tools give you
a very simple way to understand what are
the differences in their in your users
what are they looking for and what are
the most important types of users you
want to optimize your game for so you
can apply the key principles that have
them talked about what are the things
that they want to look for and and how
can we please as many users as possible
keeping one game and what in one
experience but when it comes to target
then you need much more detailed
information about every user and not
just a sample of users and that's where
player stats API comes into play you can
integrate this for free again and it's
quite simple I've been told and you get
a lot of information about your users
not only basic stats that you normally
expect from this kind of API is like
session and spends percentile and
average session length and number of
sessions or days in Schloss played all
very important information to understand
what type of user that user is but also
you get predictive analytics this is
super cool this is a probability from 0
to 1 for the user to spend and a
probability from 0 to 1 to churn we even
recently introduced to more granular
metrics same predictive analytics so the
probability to become a nice spender and
to spend in the next 28 days and what is
really cool about this is that if this
information is not just calculated based
on the behavior of your players in your
game but your players on other gains so
you get the power of what of our machine
learning and the way there is that the
information that we get by them signing
in in all these games and you can use it
to better target them what I mean by
better target them is very clear in this
simple example but I think it's very
powerful this is a intent intent the
invent venture and they use the player
stats API to make sure that as they grew
their
rewarded ads revenues they didn't
cannibalize their in-app purchase
revenues so what they did is that they
showed reward ads only to the users that
were less likely to spend and they
didn't show them to the users that were
actually likely to spend so in a way
they try to monetize different users
based on their purchase behavior and
their propensity to spend again without
having to do much on the analytics side
because they just got an input from the
player stats API and that input was
based not only on their be on the those
player behavior in their game but also
on all the other games that they played
that at Google Play game services but
that's just an example you got some
ideas from Fred Stoll called how you can
actually start thinking about different
types of users and target them here are
some other ideas just how to use this
this data you can for example target
high session length and frequency so
basically the most avid avid players on
your game with a reward and you can get
the information about them again
included through the player stats API
you can also target users that I risk of
churn with some time limited special I'm
item that I can get if they get back to
your game as soon as possible you can
reach them with a notification you know
who they are because they have a high
probability to churn and you get that
from the player stats API you can then
target users that are more likely to
spend with a special offer just to make
sure that you convert them and customize
that bundle or that offer to be a bigger
one maybe a bigger value with a higher
price point for the ones that are likely
to become high spenders so you get the
idea
again most of the ideas will come from
Fred part of the presentation but now
you have the tools to start without
having to do much in terms of analytics
and and understanding users so the sky's
the limit here but I want to leave you
with a last very basic concept that I
saw many developers even the ones that
are getting very advanced in this
sometimes they oversee this and forget
about it
the biggest difference between user is
still where they are based country
matters a lot I know it sounds intuitive
but sometimes we with machine learning
and analytics and all that we forget
about the basics and especially when it
comes to pricing you need to make sure
that your price is relevant for the
country where the user is based and if
you do a/b testing for your pricing you
should do it a country level and we are
very we think that this is a very
important part of monetizing
and that's why we we've been also
addressing this with introducing new
minimum prices for some currencies and
some markets that have different higher
prices easily say and different
purchasing power and these are some the
big ones in total we introduced this for
12 countries both in amia
and Asia so check it out in the
developer console you have access now to
a much lower price that you can use in
those markets where conversion is more
difficult but it's still you can still
extrapolate value from that so thank you
very much
you